giá vang tăng dành cửa hàng thông báo hết hàng,
Nhưng người dân vẫn sẽ hàng trở khi bỏ mô được dù chỉ một chiếc.
Chưa miệnh tháng mười giá vang miếng
EDCC lên tới 1 chăm năm 2018 đồng một lượng
cao nhất từ chựa đến nay,
và những chân cụ trạm 1 1 chăm năm 2020,
tình trạm khăn hiểm và vang diễn dễn ra tại nhiều khởa hàng ở Hanoi.
Tại cơ sở bảo ký miệng châu,
dù châu biển thông báo hết hàng,
sau người dân vẫn trên nhau chờ đời.
Hôm nay đã gái tính tấu rồi.
Khôi đi, nhưng mà hôm của vang để mở mô được chân lần dầu đây đông quá.
Háng của vang không chêu được đến cơ.
Chưa tức này vang.
Tại thành phố chiming tình trạm 1 cùng khăn hiểm của sĩnh ra,
nhiều cơ hàng tại khương ra định thúc báo,
vang miếng EDCC đã hết.
Chị còn vang nhấn chính chính chính,
mất người được mô tối đa một chi một ngày.
Bái gì ở đây,
có thứ hồng mười hai dưới nước dàng,
hãy làm có thể như thế,
có hiểu hồng hình hộ hả lần nữa.
Chị nghĩ được thế,
rất thằng lần,
thái cộp chế,
đã đi lên của vang trong nước cùng chiều giá thế giới,
từ đầu năm giá vang đã tăng khoảng 30%
gió anh hưởng của các thằng địa chính trị.
Khi vọng mi hạ lại xuất,
như cầu giảm của thuộc vào đông đô làm mi,
lực mô của các nhanh chú hương và quy etc vang.